The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So last time, we
introduced this threshold
metric for the black hole.
And then this rs gives the
horizon size of the black hole.
And then, there are two very
important geometric quantities
for the black hole.
One is the so-called
area of the horizon,
which is the area of
this s2 at the horizon.
And that the other
is what is called
the surface gravity,
which is essentially
given by 1/2 of the derivative
of this function, f,
evaluated at the horizon.
And if you value it on this,
then this gives you 1 over 2
rs.
OK.
So those quantities, we
will see them very often.
So now we talk a little bit
more about the causal structure
of the black hole.
So before I start, do
you have any questions?
OK.
So to understand the structure,
the space-time structure
of a black hole, a
little bit better,
let us look at the geometry
view of the horizon.
Because horizon is clearly
one of the most important part
of the black hole geometry.
So let's consider the
region near the horizon.
So this is for r greater than
but close to the Schwarzschild
radius.
So, for this purpose, you
can expand this function, f,
so near the horizon you can
say rs plus f prime, et cetera.
And this sum is equal
to 0, so we essentially,
when you expanded
this function f,
so that's essentially
what you have.
OK.
Then here, then they
have all the terms,
but they can be neglected if
we are close to the horizon.
So let's put this
insight into here.
But to write this metric in a
slightly more transparent form,
it's convenient to consider
the proper distance.
Also consider the
proper distance.
Say suppose you are a stationary
observer sitting at some,
say, some value of
r, then you're asking
what is the proper
distance from the horizon?
And that can be just read from,
by integrating this distance.
So essentially, d rho, so
rho, the proper distance,
should given just by dr
divided by square root of f.
OK?
You can read it from here.
AUDIENCE: Can you--
can you give us
a reminder what's
proper distance?
HONG LIU: The proper
distance is the distance
of a local observer.
Just from local
observer the [INAUDIBLE]
looks like a flat
space-time, and then that's
the distance measured
by that observer.
Yeah.
Similarly, which is the
local proper time, et cetera.
So then, by using this, then
we find here the horizon,
then we can write this as,
say, dr plus higher order
corrections, so now if
you integrate this rho,
and the setting rho equal
to 0 to be the horizon,
then we find rho
equal to-- yeah,
I just integrate that equation,
which can be easily integrated,
under the integration
constant is chosen,
so rather rho is equal
to 0 add to the horizon,
then you find the proper
distance from the horizon
is proportional to the square
root r minus rs of this.
Yeah.
So now we could rewrite to the
f itself, in terms of this rho,
OK?
So if we rewrite the f
in terms of rho itself,
so f is just f
prime, r minus rs.
And a square root r minus rs
equal to rho times this factor.
So we said this be
algebra, you can see
plus higher order corrections.
OK?
And this oh, so
now you recognize
this is essentially just
the surface gravity.
So near the horizon,
this function
f can be written as
kappa square, rho square,
then plus higher
order corrections.
So now we can rewrite
to the horizon.
Now we can rewrite this
metric in terms of this rho.
The ds squared.
Now equal to [INAUDIBLE]
Kappa square,
rho square, dt square,
plus the rho square.
So you're thinking
about definition,
this term just becomes 0 square.
And f I replace by this
kappa square rho square.
And to the leading order, I just
replace this r square by rs,
because we are close
to the horizon.
So now I can slightly
rewrite this.
So I introduce a variable.
So let me introduce a variable,
eta, equal to kappa times t.
So essentially just
t divided by 2 rs.
So with that range
of eta, then this
becomes minus rho
square to eta square,
plus d rho square, then plus
rs square d omega 2 square.
So this is just a s2.
This is a two-dimensional
sphere with a radius
given by the horizon sides.
And then these, some of
you may already recognize.
This is, in fact, just
a Minkowski spacetime.
This is a 1 plus 1 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
OK?
So this is actually
a 1 plus 1 dimension
Minkowski's time retain
in the special coordinate.
So, in the so-called
Rindler form.
The so-called Rindler form.
OK?
So we see then either the
horizon, the spacetime geometry
have the structure of
a 1 plus 1 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime, times
a two-dimensional sphere.
So now let me elaborate
this a little bit,
on why this is
Minkowski's space.
OK?
So do you have any
questions so far?
OK.
Let's just start.
Let's consider 1 plus
1 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
OK, now you're going to
see 1 plus 1 to here, done.
I will write it in
the following form.
I call my T-- So to
distinguish with the t
and there-- so let me call it
capital T, and capital X. OK?
So this is our familiar 1 plus
1 dimension Minkowski's time.
So now I will introduce
a new variable.
So make a coordinate change.
OK?
So I just plug this into there.
So let me call this m2.
So you just plug in them
there, and you immediately
see that ds square m2 is
just precisely we see there.
OK?
So this metric, so this
part of the metric,
you see, in fact, flat.
But this coordinate,
rho eta actually
does not cover the
full Minkowski space,
because, just by definition,
this coordinate satisfy x
square minus t square
equal to rho square.
Because this is [INAUDIBLE].
So this, by definition,
satisfy x square minus t square
actually greater
than equal to 0.
And also, just by definition,
because we will take rho
to be positive, and by
definition, the x is positive.
OK, we will take rho positive.
Greater/equal to 0.
So let's take rho
greater/equal to 0.
And which is what
we are having here,
because this rho is related
to the proper distance
from the horizon
is, by definition,
a non-elective quantity.
So here we also want to restrict
to rho greater/equal to 0.
And so it's easy to draw
what part of Minkowski
spacetime this is.
Let's plot it-- T, X-- so
we have the light cone.
So this occupies the region
which x-- so x can be positive,
so have to be on the right side.
But also, we have x,
the absolute value
of x must greater than
absolute value of t,
because this thing
is greater than 0.
So that means it must
be cover this region.
And this is, let's say, this
is [INAUDIBLE] x equal to t.
And this is T minus equal to x.
So these are the two light
cone, and so they can only
occupied that region.
You can also show-- let me
erase those things here,
so it's only in this quadrant.
So now let me erase these, so
that I can draw further lines.
Not to make things too messy.
So you can also just
invert this relation.
So if we invert
this relation, then
you see that the rho
square equal to x
square minus t square
under the tangent times
eta equal to t divided by x.
So that means that the
constant rho should correspond
into constant x
square minus t square,
and that's just hyperbola.
So this is a constant rho.
Say this is rho
equal to constant.
OK?
And from here, the constant
eta will corresponding
to constant slope
between t and x,
so the constant eta
will be corresponding
to the straight line, like this.
OK?
So, essentially, we
see that this metric
covers this part of
the Minkowski 1 plus 1
dimensional them
Minkowski's time,
but 48 the Minkowski's time
using coordinate like this.
OK?
So now, on this
light cone, so there
are two special lines here.
One is x equal to t,
which is essentially
the boundary of this region,
so here is when rho equal to 0.
So now you look at is
formula, where rho equal to 0,
when rho close to 0-- oh, maybe
we should do it in the limit.
So when rho approach 0, in
order for x and t finite--
so on this [INAUDIBLE], of
course, x and t are finite.
Then the eta has
to go to infinity.
So that means the light cone
[INAUDIBLE] rho equal to 0,
and the eta goes
to plus infinity.
OK?
And the [INAUDIBLE] rho
exponential eta finite.
And similarity, t equal
to minus x, this line,
then goes 1 into rho
goes to 0, but now
eta goes to minus infinity.
And when eta goes
minus infinity,
then the minus sign here will
dominate the t and the rho
exponential minus eta finite.
OK?
And so there's a
special point here
that goes 1 into x
equal to t equal to 0.
So this goes 1 into
rho equal to zero,
and any finite eta, say, will
correspond into that point.
OK?
So we see that this is precisely
what describes the black hole
horizon.
OK?
And if back here you've
got rho equal to 0,
precisely lie on the
black hole horizon,
so from here, we conclude,
so the black hole
horizon is corresponding
to x equal to plus minus t.
OK?
Here you also see, so
this rho and the eta
is essentially simple
transformation of what
we have here, r and the t.
So we also see, just
from this discussion--
so we see that the
black hole horizon just
is mapped to the light
cone in the 1 plus 1
dimensional Minkowski's
time, and that the region
outside the black
hole just mapped
to that quadrant of the
Minkowski spacetime.
So we conclude that the
little black hole geometry,
near horizon black
hole geometry.
So this is called Rindler space.
So we see that the near
horizon black hole geometry
is just Rindler times s2.
OK?
In particular, it's precisely
have this causal structure.
You have a light cone which
comes 1 into the horizon.
So that also shows that the
horizon is a long surface,
because the horizon comes
1 into the light cone.
And so we can just directly
translate that picture from rho
into t and r.
OK?
So this is just r.
You go to rs.
So eta goes to-- So
here, is that the rho
equal to 0, of the eta
goes to plus infinity.
So here is the rho goes to 0,
and eta goes to minus infinity.
So that means, for
the black hole,
this will cause 1
into i equal to i s,
and the t goes to
positive infinity.
And t and eta just differ by
this constant factor, and so
essentially the same thing.
And here, rs t equal
to minus infinity.
And then similarly,
near the horizon,
the constant r surface
will be like this,
just like a hyperbola in the--
and then the constant t surface
will also like this.
OK?
And then, of course, the full
spacetime would be times s2,
so you should imagine each
point on this plot, which
only plot r on the t
plane, so each point there
this s2 with this
radius over i rs.
OK?
Any questions on this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
meaning of the arrow
on r equals constant hyperbola?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the meaning
of the arrow on the r equals
constant hyperbola?
HONG LIU: Ah.
That's just come from here.
So from here, once we
map to these coordinates,
we see that the rho
constant because 1
to hyperbola like that.
And the rho is essentially
just related to r
by a simple transformation.
So constant the rho surface
is also the constant the r
surface, because
they are related
to a similar transformation.
So the constant r surface must
also be a hyperbola like that.
AUDIENCE: But why is there
an arrow pointing to that?
HONG LIU: Oh, the arrow just
to show that the time goes up.
Yeah, Here you can
also show arrow,
which is the direction
which the eta increases.
Yeah, so this is the
direction which time goes up.
And the time goes up, and, yeah.
Other questions?
OK.
Now let me make some
further remarks.
So some of them just repeat
what I just said, just so
that we have it here.
So observer at r equal
to constant, but r
say slightly outside the horizon
for black hole, black hole
geometry corresponds
to an observer with rho
equal to constant in
Rindler patch of m2,
OK, of two-dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
And then this is
observer which follows
a hyperbolic trajectory.
OK?
So it goes like that.
So this is not the
standard observer.
This is a hyperbolic observer.
Yeah?
So such observer which
has a constant r,
they're not the standard
initial Minkowski observer.
They travel in hyperbola.
So now you can
check easily, just
by working with this flat
space, because we know
everything about flat space.
You can easily work out.
So you can easily
check yourself.
It's an elementary calculation.
Take you a couple minutes.
Such observer has a constant
proper acceleration,
which is given by a
equal to 1 over rho.
OK?
So you can also translate
into black hole language, when
we converted this rho into rs.
So this becomes 1/2 rs.
Yeah.
Then they make us just
including the whole thing.
So you can see
from this formula,
so this is a local proper
acceleration of observer,
as we discussed yesterday.
If you want to be-- because
a black hole attracts things,
so if you wanted
to stay at a fixed
radius outside the black
hole, you need to accelerate.
You need to have
some acceleration.
And this is just
that the acceleration
close to the black hole.
And, in particular, you
see this accelerating
goes to infinity when
you approach the horizon.
OK?
When you approach the horizon.
So just a side remark-- let
me put here, side remark.
So this is related once the last
remark, the last thing we said
yesterday, is that
the surface gravity is
the acceleration of an
observer at the horizon,
near the horizon
viewed from infinity.
OK?
So the infinity.
So that formula, so
that ar, so that formula
is the local acceleration.
And you can easily
convince yourself
the acceleration at
infinity is related
to the local acceleration by
a [INAUDIBLE] factor precisely
given by this.
And if you just
take that formula,
and multiply it by this,
then you find precisely
1/2 f prime rs, which is kappa.
OK?
Which is kappa.
So this also give
you a derivation
of this surface gravity,
this formula for the surface
gravity.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Why is [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's where
I ask you to check yourself.
Yeah, I said it's a couple
minutes calculation.
It's flat space.
So you should be able to do it.
Any other question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the definition
of proper acceleration?
HONG LIU: Yeah, it's
acceleration in the local rest
frame of that observer.
Yeah, anything you
call the proper
is something which is defined
in the local rest frame
of that particular observer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the
expression for the [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
It's, say the a mu,
say it's a vector,
say it can be defined a mu
equal to u nu plus nu u nu.
And so, this u nu is the local
trajectory of that observer.
So this is the definition.
You can see it in the TR book.
So that's the local--
so that's a velocity
vector of the observer.
U mu.
OK.
So this is the first thing.
The second thing-- Yeah, so
if you check in this Waltz
book which I wrote last time.
I put the reference in the
Waltz book, and he can find it.
Or he can find it in any
GR book, they explain it.
So now, a free-fall observer
near the black hole horizon,
they just gave
you, just goes one
into inertial observer in
Minkowski spacetime, OK,
in M cube.
So this is easy because
they map to each other.
So free-fall observer is
observer in the black hole
spacetime, which
just follow from,
say some time like geodesics.
And we know that in the time
like geodesics in the Minkowski
space is just straight line.
Just straight line.
So for object fall
into to the black hole,
you just follow a straight line.
So this provide the very simple
description of an [INAUDIBLE]
observer near a black hole.
So this is the second remark.
So the third remark is that
this Rindler coordinates rho
eta, as we see from
here, become singular.
And the rho equal to 0.
Yeah, you see to describe
those rho equal to 0
to describe the
horizon, you have
to take a [INAUDIBLE] limit.
There's no longer
one-to-one relation
between the capital X and
T, and the rho and the eta.
So, for this just explains that
the Schwarzschild coordinates--
so the same thing happens
with the Schwarzschild
coordinate at the horizon.
In the same way
the Schwarzschild
coordinates become
singular at the horizon.
OK?
At the same way.
But we do understand
in Minkowski spacetime,
we know that the
reason this-- we do
know the actual
Minkowski spacetime have
four patches, rather than just
a single patch, rather than just
the single quadrant.
And so, just by
changing the [INAUDIBLE]
to a different coordinate,
this capital X and capital T,
we can actually describe the
full Minkowski spacetime, not
just the single quadrant.
OK?
So let me call this region one.
So now let me call this,
so this Minkowski spacetime
separated by light cone into
four regions-- I, II, III, IV.
OK.
I hope this is clear.
There are too many
things on the blackboard.
But by this quadrant is I,
this top quadrant is II,
this right quadrant is
III, and the bottom is IV.
OK?
So even though this
Rindler coordinate
become singular rho equal to 0,
by using Minkowski coordinates,
standard Minkowski
coordinates, x and t,
we can actually extend this
region I to the full Minkowski
spacetime.
OK?
To the full m2.
To the full Minkowski spacetime.
So now he's becoming mechanical.
So now, you must be,
because this is essentially
what describes the black
hole near the horizon.
Then in the black
hole you must be
able to find the
set of coordinates
to actually extend
beyond the horizon.
OK?
So, similarly, by changing
to suitable coordinates,
one can-- so this is normally
called the Kruskal coordinate--
we will not need to use it,
so I will not write it down
explicitly.
It's just a generalization of
this-- going to this capital
X and T. So in the
black hole geometry,
by going to these
Kruskal coordinates,
the counterpart
of this Minkowski
coordinates, one can also extend
the Schwarzschild geometry
to four regions.
OK?
Just like this
region in Minkowski
can be extended to four
regions, and this region
outside the black hole horizon
can be extend to four regions.
OK?
And we can, in fact, immediately
just modeled on here,
going from here to the
full Minkowski spacetime,
we can just immediately
extend this,
so we can immediately extend
the black hole geometry
into four regions.
The only difference--
of course, this picture
is only precise when you
are close to the horizon.
So once are you far
away from the horizon,
so those corrections
will become important.
OK?
But those don't change
the basic causal structure
of the black hole, which
are essentially determined
by the horizon structure.
So essentially,
just add to the--
in terms of the
causal structure,
this picture just extends to
the full black hole spacetime.
OK?
And in particular, say
if go this way, go to r,
go to infinity, and
there's a slight subtlety,
slight difference,
from this picture,
it's because black
hole eventually becomes
singular when r equal to 0.
So black hole have a
singularity at i equal to 0.
And that happens
inside the horizon,
so this happens in this region.
So eventually you will
reach i equal to 0.
You will reach some
singularity, so we will draw it
by some wavy lines.
And also there's a
singularity in the past.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Is the Gordon transformation the
same as from Rindler to flat?
HONG LIU: It's very similar.
Of course, it's not identical,
because that Rindler is only
valid close to the
horizon, and we're
away from the horizon
things become different.
Yeah, but qualitatively,
they're very similar.
The precise mathematical form,
of course, are not the same.
AUDIENCE: And on the
horizon, they are the same.
HONG LIU: Yeah,
essentially the same.
Any other questions.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does it
make sense, just
from a mathematical
point of view,
to have a piece of Minkowski
spacetime on its own?
You just, the manifold
is only that quadrant?
HONG LIU: Yeah, sure.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Could a
similar thing happen
in the case of a black hole,
that the inside is simply
the manifold does
not extend into it?
HONG LIU: Sure.
Yeah.
It can happen.
But, one thing, so here we
are making a basic assumption,
is that you can fall
into a black hole.
And from this picture,
we know that falling
into a black hole, from
Minkowski point of view,
means something very trivial.
Just cross that light cone.
And so this region must exist.
So let me call this
I, II, III, IV.
So this region must exist.
OK?
Yeah, so let me make
some further remark.
In this three, then it
may become clear to you.
Say these are the
remarks for this diagram.
He said when you fall
into the black hole,
you enter region II.
Because time goes up,
And clearly, because
this is a light cone,
so if you draw a light
cone inside the horizon,
no matter what point
you draw the light cone
inside the horizon,
there's no way
you can cross outside
across this surface.
OK?
So clearly, no information
or observer in region
II, can reach region I. OK?
So we call this
a future horizon.
We call this a future horizon,
because once you go beyond it,
you cannot influence
here anymore.
So we call this
a future horizon.
OK?
So another comment is
that regions III and IV,
just like in Minkowski
case, can be obtained.
from I and II by time reversal.
OK?
Yeah, actually, not precisely.
Only region IV.
Only region II.
Let me see.
Region IV can be obtained
from II by time reversal.
Yeah, by time reversal.
So for the real back hole,
for region III and IV
do not exist for real black
holes formed from collapse.
Formed from collapse.
OK?
So in some sense,
regions III and IV
are artifact of we are
working with a time reversal
in [INAUDIBLE] geometry.
So also, again, if you draw
the light cone in the region I,
there's no way you can
send signals to region IV.
OK, again, because of the
light cone, it's going that,
so there's no way you can cross
into the-- so the light radius
no way can reach region IV.
So observer in region I
cannot influence-- oh,
this is already finished.
Influence IV.
Maybe I should go back to here.
Cannot influence region
events in region IV.
So that's why this one is
called the past horizon.
OK?
So this is called
the past horizon.
So the final remark r the
diagram, is that r equal to 0.
Of course should be.
So if you go into
the r equal to 0
cause light inside
to the horizon.
And so r equal to 0 is the
black hole singularity.
So notice that
outside the horizon,
the constant r surface
goes like this, OK.
But when you go inside the
horizon, as we remark before,
the f will change sine,
then the rho between t and r
will switched.
So r actually become time.
So that's why r equal to 0 like
a constant time surface, OK?
And so is like this.
And then this just a
time reversal of that.
So this is called the
spacetime singularity.
So this is a
spacetime singularity,
because r become time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this is a time
reversal in variant geometry,
but so is it possible for there
to be time reversal, a time
reversal in processes that
are not time reversal?
That you cannot time reverse
in a time reversal in variant
geometry?
HONG LIU: Of course, in the time
reversal in variant geometry,
there certainly exists processes
which it does not respect.
Time reversal in variants.
That can happen.
But for each such process,
there's a mirror process.
AUDIENCE: So in the case
of crossing from I to III,
I guess you can cross from I
to II, but not from II to I,
but you can cross from IV to I?
HONG LIU: Yeah, you
can cross IV to I.
AUDIENCE: So that's
like a mirror process?
HONG LIU: Yeah, That's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what does it really
mean about the inside the
horizon the space and time
[INAUDIBLE]?
I mean, mathematically
it's [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Physically, if you are
a local observer you will not
feel anything.
From a local observer
point of view,
when you cross the
horizon-- So this
is just related to our
choice of coordinates.
Just imagine from here,
we'll cross from here.
Of course, nothing
really happens.
Yeah.
Here, the reason--
yeah, just the t,
we just related to the
rho of t and r switch.
T and r, they just coordinated.
They're not-- Yeah, it's just
how you describe the system.
You can prefer not
to use t and r.
Then cross the horizon,
nothing really happens.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
euclidean formula,
you cannot cross the horizon.
HONG LIU: Yeah, and we will
talk about euclidean later.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you
specify that it's
real black holes from collapse?
HONG LIU: Maybe I should
just equal black holes, not
imaginary black holes.
Yeah, just say black holes.
Yeah, real life black holes.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, then I was getting
neglected [INAUDIBLE].
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
space lights.
HONG LIU: Sir, you
have something.
AUDIENCE: And don't they
take infinite time to form?
Don't they take
infinite time to form?
HONG LIU: The black hole?
No, they take-- gravitational
collapse always take finite,
always take finite proper time.
Say, from the
observer in infinity,
and you will have the
phenomenon because
of the infinite redshift.
And then, seems like they will
never pass through the horizon.
But eventually they will.
Eventually you cannot see them,
because the light ray will
become dimmer and
dimmer, et cetera.
Yeah.
Anyway, so this is
a standard question
in GR of what happens before
the black hole collapse.
Yeah, they do collapse.
Does this answer your questions?
No?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I cannot do the
whole GR course here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to ask-- so
how long does it take
for the observer's frame?
The time it takes from
the horizon to hits
the r equals to 0 singularity.
HONG LIU: Well, then
you just calculate it.
AUDIENCE: Is it finite?
HONG LIU: Yeah, it is finite.
AUDIENCE: Then how does it feel?
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] suddenly stop
when you hit the singularity?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Before you hit the singularity,
you'll already be killed.
[LAUGHTER]
So the curvature
will become very big.
The curvature will be very big.
And, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] quantum
fluctuation spacetime.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So what we believe is that this
singularity-- so the curvature
will become infinite here.
So before you reach here,
you're already, say,
be killed by the tidal
force, et cetera.
But we do believe
that the curvature,
this curvature singularity, must
be just a mathematical artifact
of using the classical GR.
Say, if you are able
to use quantum gravity,
then there should
not be a singularity.
But there are even debate
whether they're even
reaching behind the horizon.
Maybe you can never
cross the horizon.
Maybe you already get
killed at the horizon.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a lot of possibilities.
Yeah.
So we don't really know.
So here, we are
using the assumption
that the things, so
there's nothing wrong,
at least from the
classical metric,
nothing wrong on the horizon,
then you can cross it.
But there have been debate
whether you can really cross it
or not.
AUDIENCE: But you'll
get killed anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
HONG LIU: But nobody knows.
Yeah, even if you get killed,
no other people will know.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Are some people
working on experiments?
[INAUDIBLE] we have
an academia response.
So we add a prohibition to a
system to see how it responses.
For a black hole, if [INAUDIBLE]
what kind of experiments?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
I think in the second
half of the class,
we will see such examples.
We will.
Yeah.
Some process, some scattering
process reached the black hole.
That can be considered as
some kind of linear response.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK, good.
So I'm running a little
bit short of time.
Maybe I should--
So does everybody
know what's a Penrose diagram?
AUDIENCE: No.
HONG LIU: So not?
Half?
Maybe half?
Raise your hand, people
who know Penrose diagram?
OK.
Yeah, let me maybe skip it now--
[LAUGHTER]
Because we will not
immediately use it.
So let me just skip
it, just because I want
to reach the next topic today.
It's a little bit
more interesting
than the Penrose diagram.
OK.
So these are all essentially
the classical physics
of a black hole.
So now we can go to
a little bit quantum.
So Hawking, in 1974,
made the great discovery
that actually, you
don't need to treat
the black hole as quantum.
If you just treat the matter
field, treated the matter,
whatever matter outside
the black hole-- so
photon, electron, neutrino--
treated those things as quantum
in the back hole geometry,
then actually, then black hole
does not appear as
completely black.
Actually, black hole
radiates like a black body.
So actually, black hole have
a well-defined temperature.
OK?
So now, we will try to derive
this black hole temperature.
There are many ways
to derive this.
The most authentic
away is essentially
Hawking's original derivation.
To really show that if you
have a gravitational collapse,
and then long after the
black hole has formed,
actually there is a still
[INAUDIBLE] radiation
coming out of the black
hole, from the perspective
of the observer at infinity.
And so you can deduce
that actually black hole
is like a black body with
a finite temperature.
And you can show that the
radiation is precisely
[INAUDIBLE] in the
semi-classical approximation.
Say treating the
geometry as classical,
but treat the quantum
field as quantum.
And then you can show
that the spectrum
is exactly [INAUDIBLE].
But we will not go
through such a derivation,
because it takes a
little bit of time.
And also, we will not lead
that particular technical tour
de force.
Yeah, it's a technical tour de
force, but we will not need it.
So I will give you a
different derivation.
And this derivation
is very simple,
but it's a little bit sleek.
It hides a lot of things.
And so I will just try to
give you a derivation first,
and then we will talk about
the funny things which
are hidden by this derivation.
OK?
So first, let me remind you,
that in the quantum field
theory, if we want to describe
a system at finite temperature,
we go to euclidean,
one way to do it is
to go to euclidean signature.
We take t equal to minus i tau.
And then you periodically
identify tau to have a radius,
to have a period identify tau
to have lens h bar times beta,
and the beta is 1
over temperature.
OK?
So there's a key
thing, this h bar here.
And we will always take the
Boltzmann constant to be 1.
So conversely, if you have
a euclidean theory which
have a periodic time, then
when you analytic continue back
to the Lorentzian
signature, then that system
should be at a
finite temperature.
OK?
Should be at a
final temperature.
So now let's try to
analytic continue.
So now the logic
is the following.
is that, let's now
try to analytic continue
the black hole spacetime
to euclidean signature.
And then I will show that the
euclidean time of a black hole
is forced to be periodic.
With some specific periods.
And so this tells
you, by consistency,
the black hole must have
a finite temperature.
OK?
So that's the logic.
So now let's do a [INAUDIBLE].
And let me keep this here.
So, for black hole, so let's
take t equals to minus i tau.
OK?
Then the euclidean
black hole geometry.
So now, again, I
go to the horizon.
I go to the horizon, and
I just take this thing.
So this is a Lorentzian
metric near the horizon.
So now I now go to the horizon.
Let's go to the horizon.
Then we find that this
euclidean metric, then just you
take this t equal
to minus i tau,
then you find rho
square kappa square tau
square plus t rho square plus
r square d omega 2 square.
OK?
So again, in analog with here,
I introduce a euclidean version
of this eta, so I introduce a
euclidean version of this eta,
which is [INAUDIBLE] theta.
So I introduce, let me
define, introduce, theta
equal to kappa tau.
OK?
So you do that-- so now I
can erase here-- then you
find this becomes
rho square d theta
square plus d rho square plus
r s square d omega 2 square.
So now, this we recognize
without any explanation.
This is just
euclidean flat space.
Euclidean flat two-dimensional
space in polar coordinates.
OK?
But with one difference, is
that, in the standard euclidean
coordinate, the theta
is periodic in 2 pi,
but here, for the black hole
case, this tau, in principal,
is uncompact.
OK?
But this metric,
as a singularity,
has a conical
singularity at the rho
equal to 0 for any
theta not equal to 2 pi.
OK?
For any theta not equal to 2 pi,
there's a conical singularity.
So this is easy to understand.
If you have things which
are now equal to 2 pi,
you can fold it, then become a
cone, and then tip of the cone
is singular.
For any theta whose
periods not equal to 2 pi.
I think you understand
the sentence.
A singular-- yeah, let
me write proper English.
It has a conical
singularity unless theta
is periodic in 2 pi.
This is proper English.
So, now the little horizon
metric will become like this.
And then we see that
this metric is actually
singular at rho equal to 0.
If theta is not
periodic in 2 pi.
But as we said, in the
Lorentzian signature,
the horizon is a
completely smooth place.
Nothing should happen there.
In particular, from
this Rindler picture,
you can just pass
through the horizon.
This just flat space.
It's nothing really
happening there.
So since to the horizon
non-singular in Lorentzian
picture, in Lorentz
signature, it
should not be
singular in euclidean.
OK?
So we conclude that this
tau that must be periodic,
so that this
redefine, this theta,
should have period in 2 pi.
OK?
So that means tau must be
periodic, with a period given
by 2 pi divided by kappa.
OK?
So that theta has
period in 2 pi.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
that metric slightly
different from the
original one, because here,
rho is forced to
be greater than 0?
HONG LIU: No, rho equal to
0 is the horizon, right?
AUDIENCE: But negative rhos are
not covered in this subject.
But negative rhos are excluded.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
In the euclidean
spacetime, negative rho
is also not allowed.
In euclidean flat space.
It's the same thing here.
Rho is a radial coordinate.
AUDIENCE: In Minkowskian time,
we had the region I and II,
like inside and out.
HONG LIU: Right.
But once you write
in this coordinate,
once your write in this
form, euclidean form,
and then this is just
really a flat space.
And rho is really a
radial coordinate.
You cannot extend rho
to negative value.
So recall that this thing
should be identified as h beta.
OK?
So now, if you consider,
say, a quantum field theory
in this black hole spacetime,
then that quantum field theory
must have a periodic
imaginary time.
And then this should be
identified with this h bar
beta.
So this tells us--
let me just write-- so
let me say recall t
is the proper time.
So this tau is the
euclidean version of this t,
but each observer
a different r, they
have a different proper time,
and t is only the proper time
for the observer at infinity.
OK?
[INAUDIBLE] the proper
time for observers
at r equal to infinity.
So we deduce from
here that observers
at r equal to infinity must feel
a finite temperature given by.
So, by identify this thing
to be h bar beta and beta
is 1 over t, so that means
t is equal to 1 over beta
is equal to h bar
kappa divided by 2 pi.
OK?
So this kappa is 1 over 2 s.
So this is 2 pi r s, and
this is h bar 8 pi GNm.
So we conclude if you want
to put a quantum field
theory in this black
hole spacetime,
then this quantum field
theory is automatically
at the finite temperature,
with this temperature.
OK?
With this temperature.
So to emphasize,
this is a temperature
to the observer at
r equal to infinity.
So you can easily work out the
local temperature for observer
at some r.
Then you just work out
the redshift factor,
since the t local, so as
we discussed yesterday,
is one half r d t
of the infinity.
So that tells you, and
the temperature should be
conjugated with the
time, [INAUDIBLE] time,
so that means that the
t local r should be,
that the t at infinity
minus one half r. ?
OK Then t for
infinity is this one.
So, yeah, just call it t.
So this is just h bar kappa
divided by 2 pi f minus 1/2 r.
And in particular, this
will goes to infinity,
as r goes to r s.
Because this f goes to 0
when you approach horizon,
because it lacked in power,
so this goes to infinity.
So the local temperature at
the horizon is very, very hot.
So at infinity, you
have this temperature.
But when you get closer
to, closer to horizon,
for any station observer,
you feel hotter and hotter,
and then become infinite
temperature of the horizon.
OK?
So black hole is actually
a very hot place,
if you want to get close to it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But didn't-- But this
metric is still the one near
the horizon.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how can we
make sure that that's indeed
the temperature at infinity?
I mean, it seems that
there's other corrections
that we have to do.
[INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Yeah, this
is a good question,
The only thing matters,
the only thing matters,
is what time you use to
periodically identify.
So the time we identify is the
time which is used at infinity.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah, because we
analytic continue this time,
and it's this tau
get identified.
And this tau is the tau used
by the observer at infinity.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So observer in other
positions, they
use different tau obtained
by analytic continuation
of this guy.
So that's why, then, you will
see a different temperature.
AUDIENCE: Well, no.
I'm asking, this
is not the actual--
we're using a
[INAUDIBLE] metric,
or [INAUDIBLE] metric, right?
HONG LIU: We're using?
AUDIENCE: We're not using
the exact metric, are we?
HONG LIU: Oh, we are
using the exact metric.
I mean, this doesn't-- so
I know what you're asking.
This tau is the exact
tau for the-- t.
We have not changed the t.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
I see what you're saying.
Yes.
HONG LIU: We just
look at the behavioral
of the metric near the horizon.
But t is still the t used
in the regional metric,
and which is the t used by
the observer at infinity.
Other questions?
OK.
Good.
So you may say, r, OK,
fine, the black hole
will have a finite temperature.
But now, if we use this relation
with a Rindler spacetime,
then we immediately conclude,
in Minkowski spacetime,
some observer must also
see a finite temperature.
OK?
So let's just-- So let's do,
for the Rindler space-- OK?
So let's write is as so this
is a Rindler space Lorentzian
metric.
Now we take, again, go to
the euclidean signature.
Let me call eta equal
to [INAUDIBLE] i theta.
And then I get the euclidean
metric, which just-- yeah,
of course it's just exactly
the same thing that we
did for the black hole, because
they are the same thing.
Near the horizon is same thing.
So that means the theta must
be identified with 2 pi.
OK?
But now, you say, observer
who use this time, eta, must
feel at the finite temperature.
OK?
So the time, which time
you use, is crucial.
And this eta is not the
standard Minkowski spacetime.
And this is the
time which-- yeah,
I forgot-- which is the time.
So for the Rindler space, is
the time which goes like this.
Yeah, it's the time
which goes like this.
This is not the
standard Minkowski time.
So for observer who
are using that time,
then they should feel to
be at a finite temperature.
Of course, the observer
who used that time
is precisely the observer
who are at the constant rho.
So if you have a constant
rho, then d rho equal to 0,
then that's the time you use.
OK?
So, but with a slight
correction-- so for observer.
So this is normally
called a Rindler observer
at constant rho, at
rho equal to constant,
then it's local proper time
as given by this guy, then t,
d t local is equal
to just rho d eta.
OK?
Then that means the
corresponding euclidean
time is related to this theta,
also by this factor of rho,
is rho d theta.
And that means that
this tau local will
be periodic in 2 pi times rho.
OK?
And again, you identify
this with h bar beta.
So that's tell you for Rindler
observer, at location rho,
you will see a temperature which
is h bar divided by 2 pi rho.
And, as we said
before, 1 over rho--
I just erased it-- is
essentially acceleration.
So this is just h a divided by
2 pi, and a is the acceleration.
So we call a equals
to 1 over rho.
So the acceleration is
equal to one over rho.
So this tells you, once
you write it in this form,
once you write in this form, you
can forget about Rindler space,
because the only physics is
now using the acceleration.
OK?
Now you can say any
Minkowski observer
with a non-zero
acceleration, will
feel to be at the
finite temperature.
OK?
Will feel at the
finite temperature.
And the finite temperature
is proportional to
its acceleration and the h bar.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And so an observer
free-falling into a black hole
will not--
HONG LIU: Yeah, will
not feel temperature.
AUDIENCE: So 0 temperature?
So even like when you're
approaching the horizon
and you're close to the
horizon, usually you
would have an
infinite temperature,
but here you're going
to have a 0 temperature?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah, so here, and besides,
this must be observer
is some constant value of r.
Yeah, must be a
stationary observer
outside the black hole.
Yeah, so let me just write
down this final sentence.
You said, in Minkowski spacetime
an accelerated observer will
feel the temperature
proportional to acceleration.
So this was first
discovered by Unruh.
So this is called
Unruh temperature.
So this was discovered by
Unruh, I think also around 1974.
Maybe 1976.
Around the time of Hawking's
discovery of Hawking radiation.
So Unruh, actually, was
very close to derive
the Hawking radiation himself.
Yeah, there were
several people who
were very close to derive
the Hawking radiation,
but only Hawking,
in the end, did it.
But then, Unruh
realized, actually
Hawking radiation is actually
the same as this phenomena
in flat space.
And so, now this is
called Unruh temperature.
OK.
So as I said earlier,
that this derivation
is very simple and powerful, and
we will use it again and again
in the future.
But it's quite sleek.
It does not tell you
where this radiation,
where this temperature
comes from.
And if you have a
black body radiation,
where does the radiation
come from, et cetera.
And so next time, we will
try to explain, physically,
where does this
temperature come from?
Yeah.
OK.
Let's stop here.